لقد انتهت عطلات الشتاء ولكن
الطقس في الخارج لا يزال
مخيفًا ويوم إجازتك التالي
طويل جدًا. إذا كان كل هذا يبدو كئيبًا،
فقد تكون مصابًا بالكآبة، حيث يتوقف جسدك نوعًا ما
ويريد السبات في
أشهر الشتاء الملايين من  يمكن أن
يعاني الأمريكيون من درجات متفاوتة من
الاضطراب العاطفي الموسمي،
ويقول كيا راي برويت، عالم النفس في كليفلاند كلينك، إن
السبب الدقيق غير واضح، وهناك نظرية تقول
أنه قد يكون بسبب انخفاض نشاط
السيروتونين في الدماغ الذي يساعد على
تنظيم الحالة المزاجية، ويعتقد البعض أن ضوء الشمس
يساعد في الحفاظ على تلك المستويات.  لماذا
يمكن أن يحدث الكآبة الشتوية عندما يحل
الظلام في وقت مبكر؟ في بعض الأحيان يتعين عليك أن
تتوصل إلى طريقتك الخاصة
لتشعر بالنشاط. يقول برويت: ابدأ
بالانخراط في الرعاية الذاتية، فالأكل الصحي
والنشاط البدني ليسا مفيدين للجسم فحسب،
بل لعقلك أيضًا.  ابق أيضًا على
اتصال بالآخرين سواء كانوا من الأصدقاء
أو العائلة، حيث يعد وجود نظام دعم أمرًا أساسيًا
وتغيير بيئتك بحيث تكون أكثر
هدوءًا. لدي أشياء من حولك
تنال إعجاب واحدة أو أكثر من حواسك الخمس
إذا حاولت الخروج من
العزلة.
قد تكون خيارات العلاج الأخرى مناسبة لك،
وقد تشعر
بإحساس بعدم القيمة أو
اليأس، وربما تفقد
الاهتمام بالأنشطة إذا استمر ذلك
لمدة أسبوعين على الأقل، فقد
يكون الوقت قد حان بالفعل للتواصل و  تحدث
إلى معالج نفسي للدقيقة الصحية أنا
آندي جايثر